you do not yet know the true power of
the dark side
star wars
hi guys it's quinn's ideas here and as
you guys know i've been watching all the
star wars movies for the first time ever
this is my review of the second movie
which is
actually episode 5 which is really
confusing but it does matter empire
strikes back
and the good news is empire strikes back
in my opinion is
miles better than a new hope it's pretty
much better in every way imaginable and
i'll get into that
in this review so as someone who's never
seen this movie before i will describe
to you
what happened in this movie so this
movie opens up
and the empire is sending out all of
these probes
to find the rebels they destroyed the
death star some time ago so they're
sending out probes everywhere
and they finally locate them they're on
this like messed up ice planet and so we
see luke and he's like back he's a
little bit better with the force he has
this fight with the yeti
chops his arm off wasn't quite as
gruesome
as the arm slicing scene in the first
movie i mean that was like
kind of gross it was like bubbling blood
and it was like gross but here just kind
of like
it seems like it was a little bit more
sanitized but super cool we see like
luke get to use the force and then he
ends up actually in some serious trouble
and has to be rescued
and then the empire attacks and it's
very very very
exciting and dramatic i actually did
like kind of enjoy those like big
things i don't know what they're called
like walking in the snow those were
pretty freaking terrifying
um but the curious thing that happens
luke gets into trouble
and we see an apparition of obi-wan
kenobi
and he tells luke go to the dagobah
system and find master yoda so while
everyone else is off doing something
else
luke is kind of like on his own quest
like on a vision quest to find his true
self and to
find his true strength and i think
that's really cool
so luke goes to the dagobah system to be
trained by this mysterious master yoda
while han solo and princess leia and the
droids
flee from the empire in the millennium
falcon so luke gets to dagobah
his ship crashes and he finds this
little green alien
i know that's yoda because i haven't
been living under a rock but i guess if
you were seeing this movie for the first
time you would have no idea
that this is actually master yoda
because he's kind of like goofy and
whimsical
and then suddenly he just straightens up
at some point he says i cannot teach
this boy
and then eventually he decides to teach
him and he's like so he's training
luke on dagobah while they're off being
chased
so i have to say also
the force as a concept has never been
clearer to me
than when yoda explains it in this movie
in the previous movie obi-wan kenobi
energy force that surrounds everything
and yada yada that just sounds like a
bunch of you know
vague cliche nonsense and i mean cliche
even in context for the time that's a
concept that pops up in all sorts of
fiction
but when yoda comes in and he explains
it
within the context of how they interact
with it as human beings you know the
dark side of the force being
giving in to your negative emotions and
letting you know
the inner monologue kind of rule you and
you know letting the
lower self kind of rule you and then the
jedi
being you know not giving into your
emotions and you know allowing your
higher self to come forth and take
charge and you know
resisting and you know that's very like
benny jesuit you know that's very benny
jesuit versus honored matrie
and i like the concept a lot
so for the first time ever the force
makes
a little bit of sense to me and doesn't
sound like complete woo-woo
a cool part of the movie is when
princess leia and han solo get chased
and they have to hide inside of this
asteroid
and they're kind of bickering kind of
flirting i actually enjoyed their
interaction in this movie i thought
it was cute definitely the height of the
asteroid scene though is when they
realized they're inside of some weird
worm's mouth and they almost get eaten
by this giant
space worm not technically a sand worm
it's in an asteroid so not technically a
sand worm
but yeah they almost get eaten by this
big worm in space and that was a really
cool scene i enjoyed that a lot
what i liked most about this movie is
it mainly centered around luke
and his internal thing his struggle with
you know
finding who he is and finding purpose
can i really do the
things that i'm supposed to do to save
my friends and to
and to move to the next level can i
really use the force in the way that
they say i can
you can tell that luke is definitely
having growing pains and struggling with
his identity
there's a very curious scene where he
goes in a cave
and in the cave there's darth vader and
luke
kills darth vader and then behind the
mask is himself
i don't know much about star wars as a
whole but i could see that scene
a few different ways maybe it means that
you know this could be you you could
become
this thing and maybe by killing it he's
choosing his faith there or maybe it's
saying
um by striking down your enemy and anger
you're no better than him and this is
the death of you too i don't know
but i like the fact that it's not
telling me
i need something to think about when i
watch a movie and you know i felt like a
new hope was just like very just like
go go go pew pew pew action action
action and this one had
the cool pew pew pew moment and action
action action
but it didn't ha it also had the deeper
moments
that i really enjoy and you know what
else i also really enjoyed
the floating sky city with lando that
was freaking awesome
and also like that's gotta be like one
of the greatest betrayals ever right
like i mean i kind of like i kind of
didn't trust lando at first
then i kind of did trust lando and then
i was like oh man lando
but then i trusted him again and he was
cool again so like that was that okay
floating city
gas planet that was so cool i gotta
admit that was really freaking cool i
don't know what to say
it's a really cool concept it was really
cool to see um
lando is a really cool character i
enjoyed all their interactions
um han solo being frozen in carbonite
um that was that was really intense that
was it was really really cool
um so that whole sequence was really
interesting to me and i enjoyed it a lot
but i did
feel really bad for c-3po when he got
like taken apart
and like got put out and chili was the
only one that cared like chewie was the
only one that even gave a crap
about helping out c3p i was like so mad
i was like
if i lived in the star wars universe i
would be like fighting for droid rights
i was like droids deserve rights you
will give
you will give the droids rights other
otherwise like
i'm coming at you with my laser
lightsaber sword
i'll be careful with this i borrowed it
from a friend so one of the biggest
moments in this movie
it's one of the most iconic moments ever
is when luke actually comes face to face
with darth vader for the first time they
have
a lightsaber battle but it's pretty
freaking clear from the beginning that
darth vader is just like kind of
not really it's like it's like that
scene
in harry potter and the half blood
prince
when snape kills let's not spoil things
it's like that scene when harry's trying
to to fight snape
and snape is just like not even trying
just like whatever dude like
i'm so much better than you that's
basically what this darth vader
luke scene was like except vader was
also
trying to tempt luke to like kind of
just give in to his anger and to join
join the dark side and you see he will
know the power of the dark side and the
true force and luke is like
no no no you killed my father and darth
vader is like no
i am your father and luke's all like
that's impossible
and he gets literally like he gets
downright strident at certain points
but anyway luke actually ends up getting
his hand chopped off like what is it
someone
people are always getting their hands
chopped off with lightsabers these are
dangerous weapons
gets his hand chopped off he falls down
this like shaft
and then another cool thing happens like
he like
reaches out to lay he like calls out to
her telepathically somehow
i got through the force or whatever it
doesn't have to make total sense
i totally understand that so he calls
out to her through the floor say leia
and then i actually really
really enjoyed the subversion
of a roll the roll switch because this
is not something that you typically saw
in movies especially like back in the
day luke becomes the damsel and has to
be rescued by princess leia and i was
like yes yes yes
so also like i have to commend princess
leia as a character too she's a badass
princess leia was badass at the first
movie she's pretty badass in this one
like she's like
running she's running [ __ ] princess leia
is running [ __ ]
and i really really appreciate that
character i bet she was a great
role model for kids of all kinds
so like i i see why so many people have
so much
love for that character it makes a lot
of sense to me
and of course there was another
character that showed up one that i did
know about because his character has
been you know parodied so much and he's
all like
i am big floating hand guy
i was wanting to see more of this guy i
think palpatine
is his name but he didn't he did all in
this movie he's just like
a big floating head guy so i imagine
that he'll show up more
in the next movie so it's curious that
you don't really like
the structure of the empire is still
vague
it is still vague but it's curious to
see that there is someone
above darth vader some sort of mentor
figure
so that's really interesting because
like how powerful is this guy
um because darth vader this dude is
powerful
so i said in the last review that darth
vader
choking people was one of my favorite
things well in this movie
he's he's he's choking everybody
everyone's just getting choked
you're getting choked you're getting
choked you're getting choked and he's
choking he's freaking choking people
like across
open space and people are just like
passing out on screens and dying
you know i would never work for darth
vader i would just join the rebels
like because like he's going to kill you
anyway if you mess up you might as well
just join the rebels
like jesus so long story short
empire strikes back way better movie
than a new hope
um just just way better in every way it
was better paced
the story was better the character
development was better costumes are
better the sets are bad everything's
just
just better it's just an improvement
over the first movie
in every imaginable way that being said
i don't regret anything that i said
about a new hope
i i i still think that like nothing made
sense in that movie and people got mad
at me with the way i was describing it
like i wasn't taking it seriously i'm
like the movie itself is not serious
a new hope felt very thrown together
like it's just like we have no idea what
we're doing and empire strikes back it
feels like it's been like readjusting
it's like okay we have an idea
of what we're doing we know how this
works we know what the story
is we have themes now it's not just like
basic
whatever all the time so yeah i do not
regret the rating that i gave a new hope
but empire strikes back i liked i had
fun
watching empire strikes back which i
can't really say for a new hope really
too much i like thought it was kind of
boring like i said
but empire strikes back it like
gave me some things to think about while
also entertaining me
and you know that's what i like that's
what i need so
i think i would give this movie honestly
a solid eight out of ten
you know i i i tend to go for like you
know way headier sci-fi in general but i
think
empire strikes back so far is my
favorite of the two
and next we'll get into return of the
jedi
which is star wars six and that'll be
super exciting
so thank you guys so much for watching
um i had fun watching this movie i had
fun making this review make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas
definitely definitely follow me on
twitter there's so many kooky antics
happening all the time
peace out guys and may the force thing
that people that like star wars say
oh he's using force
[Music]
what's your name dude see this guy he's
cute
he's cute you know i'll be finding out a
little bit about this guy
in that in that once i get to that that
show that everyone loves
uh baby yoda so cute so is he like
yoda's baby
is that the deal don't tell me go tell
me peace guys
[Music]
[Music]